élevé s'il a pris son bain sur une
valeur quand même s'il vient dire qu'ils
leur
essence était saoul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
justement la retraite souvent un
exercice de style et de communication
chez les rappeurs vous l'aviez annoncé
puis finalement vous y relancer pourquoi
qu'est ce qui vous a fait changer la vie
de ça cartonne froid non c'était c'était
vrai faux en même temps c'était plus une
retraite dans le sens où je veux plus me
mettre une pression à sortir des albums
ouais donc c'était mon dernier album
entre guillemets short des au feeling
d'exiger un son prêt que je kiffe je me
sens bien ça arrive c'est comme annoncer
sa carrière très tôt pour plus mettre de
pression
à 36 ans mathieu non jeu prévu sur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
wii nicolas alors lui c'est le rasseoir
ouais c'est le mec le plus endommagé nos
positions j'ai comme un droit de vous
poser toutes les questions en tant que
père de famille il ya pas mal de débats
autour des textes des rappeurs 80 ans
attise un peu la haine ou sont très
portés sur le sexe sur les trucs qui
sont des tubes qui sont revenus à raison
de dix onze douze ans je voulais juste
avoir votre position par rapport à ça
bah moi je n'aurais pas appris français
comme ça c'est réglé
mais c'est vrai qu'on parle anglais
c'est pas pour ça mais parle pas
français donc que d'accord très bien
voilà la réponse mais ça mérite d'être
une réponse mais les autres pour les
autres enfants bah les autres les autres
je suis pas le père de l'humanité non
bien sûr mais la position passe alors le
temps de leur dire ne pas écouter du
bois
vos enfants qu'ils écoutent du bout du
bout bas ma fille elle adore le râble
donc l écoute moi je suis un artiste
donc je quand j'écris je me dis pas que
tu écris pas en pensant aux enfants ou
pensant donc si je prenais un tableau je
prends mon tableau me pose pas la
question isabelle vos arrières
petits-enfants etc
non mais ce qu'ils écoutent je suis très
fan de raymond si je sais que guillaume
très fan nicolas pernikoff j'adore le
son mais par contre de temps en temps ce
qui me pose un problème c'est sur les
taxes à rien je vous dis alors et qui tu
fais battu cauchemar tu peux pas dire ça